Let's go next to Abby from Idaho,
Abby from Idaho, you're on the air.
Hello, yes, you're on. Hi, how are you?
How are you doing? Well, thank you.
So I actually live in Washington State right
now. I'm in the Navy, so I'm stationed out
there. But I was I was born in Idaho.
Oh, OK. Well, yeah, but we birthplace
residents. It's all fine.
Yeah. I was just curious what
because I was talking to some of the guys I work
with which most military band members are actually
kind of libertarian, more than I'd say Republican.
Right. But I was asking them if they would accept
court decisions on these voter fraud cases.
Right. And I wonder what you think the Trump
supporters are going to do. You know, in the
courts, obviously come back and say there's
not any voter fraud that they're going to accept.
If these state delegates decide to go for Trump,
they're going to be, you know, on that bandwagon
if you're talking about faithless electors,
right? Yeah. Do you think that they're going to
be on the electoral bandwagon or do you think
that they're going to accept the election?
I mean, so they're kind of two different
questions. The first question is, if Joe
Biden eventually if courts say they didn't
find any voter fraud, there are going to be
some. Trump is to say the courts are biased
and there are some Trump as to who might accept
it. OK, if you end up having a situation where
there are faithless electors, my guess is a
libertarian would say, hey, the the electors
are allowed to go the opposite way of their state
if they believe that it is important to do so. So
my guess is that the libertarian leaning folks
you're talking about would be fine with it.
I don't expect that to happen. I think that, you
know, we've had faithless electors in the past,
but they've never reversed the results. And with
such a margin for Joe Biden, you're not going
to get 20 or even 36 potentially. Depending how
Georgia goes, you're not going to get that number.
Yeah, and that's that's kind of what we talk about
at work, and I also feel really bad for some of
these guys because they are Republicans,
but not necessarily Trump supporters.
And they have a you know, at least like a
can have thoughtful political discussion.
And I feel like these Trump supporters are kind
of bringing down their ability to have like a
reasonable discussion right now where you're
saying you feel bad for anti Trump Republicans.
Yeah, I kind of do, because I do think
that having difference to the political
discourse is important. I'm a progressive
and I wish that everybody would be for
Medicare for all and and all the things I want.
But I realize it's not a reality, you know.
Yeah, that's fair. I mean, I think, you know,
let's let's keep everything in context. I
feel worse for the families and victims
of coronavirus than I do for anti Trump
Republicans who might be struggling
to have conversations right now. But
the point is still well, I understand what
you're saying, that the pro Trump people,
they just want to shut everybody down, anti Trump,
Republicans, Democrats, progressives, everybody.
Yeah. And I just want to think, you know, I know
all of your listeners, at least the progressive
ones, are definitely abiding by social distancing
and mask Maheswaran. And you may not realize this,
but the the military is taking this very
seriously. I am aware of it. I am aware of it.
Yeah. And for instance, like I got in contact
with the guy at work who is covered positive for
like maybe all of five minutes. And because of
that I was stuck home for two weeks. You know,
I did a huge contact tracing at work, which is
how everybody should be doing it, really. But
because of that, me and my sailors that work for
me, we really can't even go home for the holidays.
Right. So it really sucks to see these Republicans
out there just freaking out about how much they
love the military, but they refuse to wear a mask.
It hurts, you know, because they're the reason why
I can't go home. Absolutely. My mom, absolutely.
Everybody who wants you have people who want
to open everything and yet they don't
want to wear masks. It's like, wait,
hold on a second. If everybody wore masks, we'd
be doing much better. Much more could be open.
Yeah, well, thanks for talking to Veterans Day.
All right, Abbi from Idaho, currently in
Washington State, thank you so much. Excellent.
Excellent. Excellent to hear from you.
Let me go next to let's go to Adam from
Irvine, California. Adam from Irvine.
What's going on? Adam from Irvine, California,
can hear background noise, you were on the air.
Well, this year, just barely.
It's got to be better, marginally,
are you running a buzz saw in the background?
No serious question, but I want to know what you.
I met with military advisers. So how are you?
Are you using an electric shaver right now?
I was the question about Trump
firing military advisers. Yes.
Oh, OK. Listen, I'm going to take it off
air because it's it's that's wild. Listen,
so Trump firing military advisors, there's kind of
two questions. One, if he's out in nine weeks, why
is he firing anybody? What difference does it make
that? So that's that's sort of like one question.
The other side of it is, is this part of a planned
military coup? I think this is just Trump's a
petulant child and he's firing people who he's
been at odds with. And he would have fired
them months ago were it not for somebody saying,
hey, you know what, you might want to wait until
after the election perfectly. To be perfectly
honest, I think it's that simple. I don't think
we should read much more into it. And, you know,
there's people acting like Trump's a criminal
genius here, staging some coup by replacing
Mark Esper. I just don't see it. I really don't.